alors nous en arrivons à notre ordre du
jour et nous vous remercions vivement
madame la Présidente d'avoir accepté le
principe de cette audition qui suit la
remise de votre rapport que je
qualifierai de d'ACA blanc sur le titre
donc porno criminalité mettre fin à
l'impunité de l'industrie pornographique
la présentation de ce rapport m'a semblé
particulièrement opportunes à la veille
du démarrage de l'examen sciences
publiques du projet de loi qui vise à
sécuriser l'espace numérique il
s'inscrit de plus et je les salue dans
la continuité de nos travaux de nos
homologues du Sénat et puis les travaux
également de notre délégation au droit
des femmes c'est une question
essentielle qui est à la croisée
évidemment de la lutte contre les
violences et de nos préoccupations sur
la santé mentale des femmes mais aussi
des hommes en particulier des plus
jeunes on l'a vu dans le rapport plus
jeune d'entre eux qui sont évidemment
notre avenir et pour lequel on a une
attention particulière je vous propose
de nous présenter sans plus attendre vos
travaux et ensuite nous organiserons un
temps de prise de parole des orateurs
puis de questions réponses si vous le
voulez bien je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente cher
Véronique je suis très heureuse de me
retrouver parmi vous aujourd'hui pour
cette dernière possibilité de rencontre
avant le la discussion séance publique
du projet de loi régulant le numérique
puisque et là la question qui m'occupe
aujourd'hui et que je vous présente donc
la porno criminalité se déroule
essentiellement dans le secteur
numérique et que cela qu'on peut agir
qu'avons-nous chercher à faire après
l'excellent rapport du Sénat qui faisait
déjà un constat accablant comme le dit
Véronique de la situation de la
diffusion de la pornographie et de ses
contenus nous avons voulu aller encore
plus loin encore plus crumblement dans
la description des pratiques
monstrueuses
j'ose le dire de la porno criminalité et
faire des propositions peut-être encore
plus forte qu'on avait eu l'occasion de
le faire de le Sénat il y a un an donc
notre constat d'abord un état d'esprit
nous ne sommes pas là pour vouloir
interdire la pornographie nous sommes
pas des censeurs ou des
personnes qui voulons mettre fin à la
pornographie nous voulons mettre fin à
ce qui est hors la loi ce qui est
contraire au droit ce qui est contraire
simplement au traitement humain des
personnes donc la fin des violences la
fin de la torture la fin de la barbarie
tout cela que l'on trouve donc
abondamment dans la pornographie et bien
sûr de manière illégale c'est ça qu'on
perd beaucoup beaucoup de vues c'est que
toutes ces séquences qui sont diffusées
enregistrées d'abord produites
diffusé saute illégales elles sont
illégales parce que on fait signer des
pseudo contrats à des pauvres futures
victimes qui se disent actrices qui ne
tiennent pas debout parce qu'elle
consente à leur propre déchéance qu'on
ne peut pas faire
c'est illégal parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit d'enregistrer des scènes de
torture de barbarie de violence de viol
sofa être sanctionné de la marma de même
manière que les gens qui commettent ces
viols on n'a pas le droit de les
diffuser
c'est une série de de
manquement au droit qui passe depuis des
dizaines d'années complètement sous les
radars les pouvoirs public n'ont pas
l'air de son offusqué et les producteurs
et les plateformes continuent à se
balader tranquillement sous le prétexte
de liberté de communication de liberté
artistique on ne voit pas très bien où
est la dimension artistique de ces
séquences mais enfin il se réfugie
derrière la liberté de création la
liberté de communication la liberté
sexuelle
nous nous disons que toutes ces libertés
s'arrêtent là où il y a atteinte à
l'intégrité corporelle et violation
du drop pénal et le droit pénal prévoit
de condamner fortement toutes ces
violences je vais vous décrire
quelques-unes de ces violences à la
demande de Véronique
donc oreille sensible s'abstenir mais il
y a parmi de nombreuses violences et il
y a pas que les violences que je vais
vous décrire il y a évidemment les
insultes
[__] [__] tout ce qu'on veut tu
aimes ça et etc
il y a presque les violences ordinaires
parce que c'est normal que les femmes
soient traitées comme étant des des
sous-êtres humains qu'ils sont qui sont
juste destinés être piétinés
et mépriser et violé par les hommes mais
il y a quelques pratiques mais
maintenant qui sont légion et qui sont
carrément banales qui apparaissent dans
ces séquences que je vais vous décrire
et qui sont incroyablement tolérées il y
a parmi elles le boukake qui va être
d'ailleurs le nom du procès qui s'ouvre
bientôt qui consiste à ce que des
dizaines d'hommes violent des femmes
avant leur éjaculer dessus donc des
manquements évidents
aux droits les viols et le la teinte à
la dignité humaine avec cet éjaculation
sur toutes ces femmes qui ressortent
évidemment non seulement abîmées
physiquement mais traumatisé mentalement
il quelque chose qui s'appelle gang bang
c'est absolument immonde c'est plusieurs
hommes pénètrent à la fois dans
plusieurs orifices en même temps l'anus
le vagin et la bouche d'une femme et
elles ont évidemment ressortent
complètement abîmée physiquement
également il y a tous les autres gestes
comme l'électrocution dans le vagin dans
la gorge le gagging c'est à dire un
pénis énorme évidemment parce qu'on les
choisit le plus gros possible
enfoncé jusqu'à l'étouffement dans la
gorge des femmes enfin je ne vais pas
vous urine aussi dessus
c'est-à-dire le rapporteur général m'a
demandé votre commission spéciale à
réunie sur ce projet de loi si je
mettais le fait d'uriner dans la bouche
des femmes dans les tortures et barbarie
je l'écoutais en tout cas je n'aimerais
pas que vous subissiez ce genre de de
traitement vous mettez ça où vous voulez
mais c'est en tout cas une atteinte à la
dignité humaine évidente ça n'a pas lieu
de rester en ligne donc il y a comme ça
une myriade de pratique de plus en plus
raffinée si je l'ai dit si je pouvais
dire
si je peux dire dans dans le sadisme le
la haine
le mépris des femmes et ces pauvres
victimes en ressortent abîmé pour la vie
et physiquement et mentalement
qu'est-ce que nous en tirons comme le
son d'abord les conséquences non
seulement pour les femmes
mais pour la jeunesse qui regarde ces
images et qui est durablement choquée et
marquer dans ces pratiques futures parce
que ça modèle les jeunes qui regardent à
notre demande l'arcom a sorti ces
chiffres les a demandé à sorti ces
chiffres qui regardent ces séquences de
plus en plus jeunes enfin un garçon de
12 ans en moyenne la moitié des garçons
de 12 ans regarde une fois par mois des
scènes de cette nature et surtout les
conséquences qu'ils en tirent 47% des
garçons nets pensent que les femmes
s'attendent les filles s'attendent à
être agressé sexuellement quand il ira
la des relations sexuelles et 42% pense
que elles aiment ça
donc après on s'étonnera pas que le taux
de féminicides augmente que les
agressions sexuelles augmentent puisque
le modèle social c'est que de faire
l'amour c'est de faire des violences
tout émêlé s'était rotisé en plus
sexe égal souffrance violence égale
jouissance c'est c'est abominable on a
l'impression que tout ça et maintenant
c'est monnaie courante c'est la norme
donc pour faire cesser ce préjudice qui
est fait à la Société ce modèle qui est
offert de violence pour faire cesser ses
violences faites aux femmes c'est quand
même la grande cause du quinquennat on
met ça en priorité des politiques
publiques donc on doit agir nous avons
réfléchi au HCE comment mieux mettre fin
à ces images catastrophiques délétères
pour la société catastrophique pour les
femmes donc une des mesures il y a
plusieurs mesures je vais pas tout vous
égrener vous trouverez ça évidemment
dans le rapport et toute notre toutes
nos publications
la mesure phare et de demander que
au-delà de la justice judiciaire qui est
très utile et qui doit continuer
évidemment à poursuivre les auteurs y
compris aussi les images mais dans un
souci d'urgence il faut absolument que
farose la plateforme de police
administrative du ministère de
l'Intérieur élimine les
séquences non seulement de viol de
violence de torture de barbarie enfin
tout ce qui est absolument contraire à
notre code pénal en matière de violence
et qui contraire à l'article de de tirer
33-3 du code pénal on n'a pas le droit
d'enregistrer diffuser de telles images
donc nous avons proposé et votre
présidente a déposé des amendements sens
que je salue que Pharos soit
maintenant responsable d'une nouvelle
compétence au-delà de la compétence
qu'ils ont déjà sur le terrorisme et sur
la pédopornographie je nous demande donc
qu'il retire aussi les séquences
concernant les violences faites aux
femmes qui sont des violences
qui en plus sont la plus part du temps
digne de la torture enfin qui relève de
la définition de la torture parce que je
sais pas si vous connaissez la
définition de la torture qui a été
ratifiée par la France dans la
Convention de New York dans les années
80 est reprise par une jurisprudence de
la Cour de cassation en 2017 la torture
est tout acte qui est une souffrance
aiguë
mental ou physique infligé
intentionnellement à une personne ça
concerne 90%
des vidéos porno et d'ailleurs c'est 90%
sont un chiffre que nous n'avons pas
c'est la procureur de Paris madame
Bécaud qui a cité ce chiffre lors d'une
audition au Sénat pour le rapport dont
nous avons parlé donc
c'est devenu ce sont devenus des
séquences entre guillemets mainstream
pour parler d'un mauvais français et
qu'il faut évidemment éliminer donc
d'abord par farose après on a beaucoup
d'autres propositions je crois que vous
en avez aussi pour
réguler mieux
la diffusion de ces images
pornographiques
dans le numérique mais ça c'est une une
image essentielle et que j'espère que
vous voterez majoritairement évidemment
dans le cadre du de la séance publique
vraiment je reviens sur le fait qu'il
faut absolument convaincre vos collègues
parce que il y a une prise de conscience
à faire pendant des années on se dit bon
il y a du porno il en faut bien ça jeune
personne porno la papa s'il y a des
types qui ça fait plaisir etc mais on en
est plus là et largement plus là et
d'ailleurs je suis contente qu'une prise
de conscience était prise au niveau des
médias d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je
vous ai apporté une revue de presse
parce que quand on a la Une du Figaro en
même temps que la Une de l'Huma suivie
de plusieurs pages on se dit qu'on a
déjà quelque part commencé à gagner la
bataille de la communication et que
trans courant transpartisans sur tous
les bancs puis il y a le monde et Libé
enfin il y a tout le monde je sais pas
tout apporter mais quand même la
manchette du Figaro sur un sujet pareil
pour nos criminalité le rapport qui
révèle l'ampleur du fléau avec les trois
pages et l'humain pareil ça fait du bien
de se dire qu'on a déjà pas travaillé
pour rien donc je pense que maintenant
c'est au parlementaire de relever le
défi je vous fais confiance pour essayer
de persuader vos collègues il faut
absolument saisir l'occasion de ce
projet de loi régulant le numérique
parce que ça va pas repasser tous les
six mois il y en a un qui est servi tout
chaud là qu'on peut compléter amender et
rendre tout de suite efficace pour la
cause des femmes merci de votre
attention je vous fais confiance c'est à
vous de jouer maintenant
merci madame la Présidente alors oui
effectivement ce projet de loi
finalement pour moi c'est une c'est une
double opportunité si je peux me
permettre à la fois pour protéger nos
enfants puisque être exposé à ces
violences c'est aussi en tout cas
essayer de limiter que ces violences ne
leur savent pas finalement d'entrée dans
la sexualité et puis protéger évidemment
les femmes et les filles car nous savons
que un manque de régulation que ce soit
pour Internet et réseaux sociaux les
sites porno en tout cas
que ça ne crée pas un nouvel espace de
perpétuation de de ces violences
sexistes et sexuelles pour que ce ne
soit pas reproduit dans la vraie vie en
tout cas vous pouvez compter sur nous
alors je vous propose maintenant de
passer aux orateurs de groupe et pour
démarrer pour le groupe Renaissance je
donne la parole à Madame Amélia la
graphie
merci Madame à présidente
madame la Présidente bravo et merci pour
le travail extrêmement fouillé et précis
que vous avez mené avec vos équipes et
qui donne à ce rapport une véritable
portée du JT public en effet il y a dans
ces lignes un électrochoc puissant
provoqué en premier lieu par le recours
à vocabulaire franc et cru pour décrire
les services perpétrés par l'industrie
du porno cette froide description donne
littéralement la nausée et c'est
précisément parce qu'elle est
insoutenable qu'elle peut susciter une
prise de conscience générale et
nécessaire y compris parmi ceux qui
pensent comme vous avez dit qu'au fond
on ne fait rien de mal dans le porno
pourtant les conséquences sont bien
réelles elles le sont pour les victimes
directes de ces sévices bien sûr mais
aussi pour notre société avec un impact
sur les jeunes que vous qualifiez à
juste titre de problèmes de santé
publique madame la Présidente vous
pointez dans ce rapport les causes qui
expliquent selon vous la persistance de
l'impunité dans ce secteur et le déni
sociétal autour de la gravité des
méfaits du porno on note une proportion
de cette industrie enfreindre les règles
sous couvertes de liberté de création et
seront pendant le caractère inopérant de
notre arsenal légal à nous législateurs
de prendre pleinement la mesure de ses
constats et je pense que nous aurons
tous et toutes à coeur dans cet ensemble
de mener ce combat il y a pour ma part
un chiffre qui m'a tout particulièrement
interpellé près de 14 millions d'usagers
de sites pornos dans notre pays la
France est le troisième pays
consommateur parmi ces utilisateurs
certains cliquent en connaissance de
cause sur des contenus dont l'intitulé
décrit ce qui s'apparente à un acte de
barbarie ou à tout le monde à des faits
de violence pénalement répréhensibles
n'y a-t-il donc pas aussi selon vous
quelque chose qui se joue au niveau de
la responsabilité individuelle et de la
nécessité de mettre celle-ci en cause
compte tenu de l'ampleur de l'ampleur du
phénomène le seul travail de prévention
et de sensibilisation auprès des jeunes
dans le cadre des heures d'éducation à
la vie active et sexuelle paraît en
effet un biomeigre réponse merci merci
alors pour un débat un peu vif et parce
que madame la Présidente le veut bien on
va faire une petite réponse courte à
chaque intervention
merci beaucoup madame député je suis
évidemment totalement d'accord avec vous
il faut évidemment commencer par
responsabiliser chaque personne et
comment d'abord par l'Éducation
nationale qui ne fait pas son travail
depuis 21 ans que la loi est votée pour
faire ses séances d'éducation sexuelle
comment voulez-vous que les jeunes
n'aillent pas regarder dans leur
smartphone des séquences porno quand on
leur explique même pas les choses
basiques à l'école qu'aurait dû être
prodigué depuis longtemps c'est vrai que
les parents ont beaucoup de mal sur ces
sujets c'est compliqué c'est mieux quand
ça se passe avec les parents mais
souvent ça ne se passe pas avec les
parents donc l'éducation et l'école
doivent prendre le relais et en
particulier vu le stade où on en est
arrivé l'éducation sexuelle m'a non
seulement être prodigué mais en plus les
mises en garde sur ces séquences porno
les décrypter dire que c'est pas ça la
vie réelle et donc faire toute une
campagne à la fois auprès des jeunes
mais des professeurs et de l'opinion en
général pour alerter sur l'état de la
situation bien sûr on ne peut pas se
contenter de punir de retirer les
séquences il faut aussi prévenir
merci pour le rassemblement national la
parole est à Emmanuel Tachet de la
Pagerie
le rapport remis le 27 septembre par le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dépanne terrifiante
réalité concernant la violence
prévalente sur les plateformes de
contenu pornographiques ce dernier
décrit un niveau de violence de torture
et d'humiliation infligé aux femmes à
des niveaux encore jamais atteint ce que
vous avez déjà justement qualifié de
massacrer illégal à but lucratif l'étude
menée sur les quatre principales
plateformes pornographiques à révélé que
90% des millions de vidéos en ligne
comportent des violences physiques et
sexuelles intolérables ces informations
scabreuses ne sont pas seulement
édifiantes mais elles mettent également
en lumière la culture du viol insidieuse
qui semble être encouragée par de telles
représentations dégradantes et
humiliantes et qui interroge même sur la
notion d'humanité le rapport souligne
aussi la déficience des autorités dans
la gestion des violences porno criminels
comme le montre l’unification des
signalements fait à Pharos la plateforme
gouvernementale chargé de lutter contre
les contenus illicites sur internet ce
manque d'action et de réactivité face à
des contenus manifestement illégaux
inhumains va au-delà de la préoccupation
dans le même ordre d'idées le rapport
fait état des contenus
pédopornographiques et critiques
l'application restrictive des mesures
existantes le nombre référent de 1,3
millions de vidéos pédopornographiques
identifiées illustre l'emplaire de cette
problématique
l'extrême gravité de ces actes nous
oblige particulièrement en tant que
législateur et non vous l'avez très bien
dit Madame comme son soeur parmi vos
recommandations vous identifiez 5
mesures qui sont du domaine de la loi
quelle mesure selon vous urgentez
immédiate jugez vous nécessaire que nous
portions au sein de notre délégation
afin de mener une action volontaire et
commune au Parlement et efficace je vous
remercie
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
monsieur le député
je l'ai dit dans le mon propos luminaire
la mesure phare si je peux dire c'est
Pharos c'est vraiment l'instrument
idoine pour en urgence mettre fin à ce
scandale parce que c'est un scandale
les
policiers sont formés
pour cela puisqu'ils le font déjà pour
le terrorisme et la pédopornographie
l'instrument est là j'en ai parlé même
au ministre de l'Intérieur il me disait
que ça me pose même pas un problème de
ressources humaines puisque
l'intelligence artificielle peut
pourvoir
à la sélection des séquences illégales
donc il faut se dépêcher de donner une
nouvelle compétence à farose et ça on
peut le voter dès la semaine prochaine
donc ça serait fantastique vous avez
dans vos mains une occasion historique
de changer un peu le cours des choses
pour les femmes et les enfants
merci
madame la Présidente collègue merci
madame la Présidente du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
pour cette présentation très claire et
la somme que votre rapport met à notre
disposition
votre rapport est douloureux à lire
parce qu'il jette une lumière crue sur
ce qui est massivement l'industrie du
porno ce n'est pas du cinéma ni de la
fiction mais bien la captation et la
fusion de violence très réelle
l'industrie pornographique est ce que le
capitalisme peut socialement produire de
pire une poignée de gagnants qui réalise
des profits gigantesques basées sur
l'exploitation humaine et puis l'immense
majorité des perdants et des perdants
les victimes directes mais aussi et
surtout les femmes dans leur ensemble
les personnes racisées les personnes
LGBT et j'en passe et bien sûr parmi les
victimes il y a les enfants et les
adolescentes les adolescents qui se
construisent une image désastreuse de la
sexualité basée sur la violence et la
domination
mon groupe partage bien évidemment
certaines de vos recommandations comme
le renforcement des moyens de la justice
nous demandons de notre côté le
recrutement de 13000 magistrats 20.000
greffiers et 10000 personnels
administratifs afin de couvrir
véritablement ses besoins surtout nous
demandons comme vous le déploiement
d'une véritable politique de prévention
qui est pour nous le point fondamental
et indispensable pour une réelle
évolution et la sensibilisation des
enfants et des jeunes à une sexualité
qu'ils doivent s'approprier eux-mêmes il
faut que les séances d'éducation la
sexualité soient enfin appliquées et que
les inclut une sensibilisation à la
pornographie à destination des enfants
bien sûr mais aussi des parents bien
souvent trop peu vigilants
[Musique]
également à l'anonymat j'aimerais donc
avoir votre avis sur ce point précis
pensez-vous réellement qu'il soit
possible de contrôler l'âge
d'utilisateurs tout en préservant le
droit à l'anonymat et à la vie privée
et enfin encore merci pour nous avoir
présenté ce rapport qui montre que le
chemin est encore long dans le combat
contre les dérives de cette industrie
[Musique]
merci monsieur le député vous soulevez
de problèmes tout à fait intéressant
la problématique du contournement du
judiciaire loin de nous cette idée nous
ne voulons que ajouter des instruments
pour la politique publique concernant la
pornographie et bien sûr que le chômage
judiciaire doit continuer nous mettons
même dans nos recommandations que ça
doit devenir numéro 1
de la politique des parquets donc il
faut que les auteurs de ces
monstruosités soient poursuivies que les
procédures puissent se développer
simplement il y a une urgence à défendre
la société contre ces images et dans
l'urgence quand il y a le feu dans la
rue on commence pas par le procès on
commence par éteindre le feu donc nous
disons bien sûr il faudra qu'elle procès
qui aura les procédures judiciaires mais
commençons par éteindre le feu et le mal
qu'il fait
aux femmes qui ont sont victimes et à la
jeunesse qui qui regarde donc pour nous
il n'y a pas du tout de mise à l'écart
de l'autorité judiciaire et au contraire
un ajout de Pharos avec elle
en matière de de technique de contrôle
d'âge je pense que il est extrêmement
compliqué de trouver le bon système ce
dont je suis certaine alors bien sûr il
faut préserver l'anonymat la liberté du
consommateur les droits fondamentaux et
enfin faut concilier de liberté c'est
toujours difficile il y a pour l'instant
paraît-il une urgence c'est qu'on n'a
pas
pris les bonnes dispositions dans le
projet de loi qui émane du Sénat sur le
référentiel qu'on se propose
de bâtir de faire bâtir l’arcome et la
CNIL pour que les sites puissent ensuite
les les installer en se disant mais
puisque c'est les pouvoirs publics qui
tous le proposent il doit être bon je
crains que cette méthode là
même si on trouve un bon système dont je
n'ai pas c'est pas notre métier moi
j'essaie de trouver le bon système même
si le bon système était trouvé et encore
j'en doute parce que c'est extrêmement
difficile
mais qu'il le suscite des recours à non
plus finir de la part des plateformes et
des sites concernés ce qui fait que ça
retarderait d'autant
la
l'élimination de ces sites et de leur
séquence monstrueuse moi je préférais le
système précédent que vous aviez voté en
2020 qui demandait aussi de mettre
eux-mêmes en place le système
idoine et si on trouvait que ce système
n'était pas idoine et n'était pas
efficace ou avait des défauts et bien
enfermer les sites ça donnait et là la
nouvelle loi donne un nouveau pouvoir
que nous que nous approuvons à l'arcome
de ne pas passer par le judiciaire pour
dire stop
peut-être que vous direz encore que on
bâille pas ce logiciel mais je pense que
c'est utile parce que on voit très bien
comment ces plateformes qui ont des
millions à dépenser en procédure en
avocat etc faut feu de tout bois pour
toujours retarder le moment de
s'incliner donc je pense que la bonne
solution c'est l'arcome qui a le droit
de constater que si le site ne met pas
en place un système efficace
conforme aux droits et à l'efficacité et
bien on le ferme voilà et bien comme ça
il y aura plus les images et les jeunes
ne seront pas infestés
par ces séquences je trouve encore mieux
qu'on arrête complètement ces séquences
comme je le disais grâce à farose comme
ça on ferait d'une pierre deux coups les
jeunes n'auraient plus à regarder ces
séquences et les femmes n'en serait plus
les victimes on réglerait le problème
complètement
merci merci pour les républicains
Virginie dubuismellaire merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente du Haut
Conseil entre les femmes et les hommes
votre rapport est essentiel il dit la
réalité de l'activité pornographique en
France et ses conséquences terribles
pour les femmes que vous qualifiez de
porno criminalité vous décrivez les
actes de torture à travers des pratiques
sexuelles violentes et dégradantes pour
les femmes et je ne vais pas citer celle
que vous avez déjà rappelé en préambule
c'est pratique sadiques qui sont
absolument insoutenables votre travail
complète celui mené de façon
transpartisonne bien sûr par le Sénat et
qui mettait déjà en lumière les graves
dérives de cette industrie qui broie les
femmes assimilées à des objets alors que
plusieurs procédures font l'actualité il
est important de rappeler que ces
violences qui sont des actes de barbarie
contre des femmes exploitées
rejaillissent in fine sur une société
qui les banalise il est donc nécessaire
de les combattre car lorsque des jeunes
hommes mineurs sont confrontés à ces
images et je rappelle que c'est environ
un tiers des jeunes de 12 ans qui sont
déjà exposés à des contenus
pornographiques et bien ensuite il
risque de reproduire ses comportements
violents vers les femmes les frapper les
insulter ou encore pire reproduire des
viols et je pense à un exemple dans ma
circonscription ou une jeune femme a été
victime d'un viol collectif et parmi les
violeurs il y avait un jeune de 12 ans
ces contenus donc participent aussi à
des crimes tels que l'inceste ou la
pédocriminalité et là aussi vous faites
des propositions et je voulais aussi
rappeler ce qui existe aussi le viol par
streaming qui malheureusement une
pratique qui s'exerce notamment avec les
Philippines ou certains comètes cela
pour 40 à 100 dollars avec parfois
malheureusement des parents complices
c'est donc tout un système qu'il faut
mieux contrôler et sanctionner avoir
afin d'avoir une société plus saine nous
comptons évidemment sur le texte visant
à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique dont nous allons débuter
l'examen demain pour encore mieux je
dirais encadrer cela d'un point de vue
juridique et nous avons déposé des
amendements je crois parmi parmi ces
rangs pour notamment que les actes de
torture soient signalés à Pharos donc
évidemment vous pouvez compter sur notre
mobilisation sur sur ce sujet et je
voulais une nouvelle fois vous féliciter
pour pour ce rapport
merci madame je ne peux que vous
remercier je crois qu'il y avait pas de
question donc je ne peux qu'être ravi et
de cet unanimité sur tous les bancs
merci beaucoup pour les démocrates
Sandrine Josso
merci madame la présidente madame
Brossolette merci et bravo pour ce
rapport à l'Armand qui fait froid dans
le veau d'eau et qui a aussi nous
permettre de lever les tabous alors vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure d'éducation
qu'elle serait selon vous les priorités
à partir de quel âge peut-on proposer
des choses est-ce que vous avez des
méthodes sur lesquelles vous avez des
choses à nous dire peut-être par exemple
dans d'autres pays européens des choses
qui ont fonctionné et puis vous avez
aussi parlé de de la loi
et de farose
y a-t-il des arguments vraiment massus
pour aussi mettre en valeur ce qu'on
pourrait proposer
via la loi qui qui arrive là à
l'Assemblée merci pour pour tous ces
éléments et à votre écoute
merci Madame donc pour l'éducation
je peux esquisser quelques
recommandations nous allons les creuser
un peu plus tard parce que ce sera sans
doute au menu des travaux du HSE
pour l'année qui vient d'ailleurs ça
occupera de voir trois commissions pour
essayer justement de proposer un mode
d'emploi complet sur qu'est-ce qu'il
faut changer dans l'éducation de ce pays
non seulement éducation sexuelle mais
après orientation des filles enfin faire
la totale de ce qu'il faut modifier pour
que ça aille mieux de ce côté là sur
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle nous pensons comme d'ailleurs
le projet de loi qui avait été voté il y
a plus de 20 ans le prévoyait qu'il faut
commencer dès le plus jeune âge dès le
primaire avec des contenus adaptés à
chaque âge évidemment avec des des
professeurs formés ça peut être aussi
des associations mais dont le corpus
puisse être complètement validé et en
accord avec l'Éducation nationale qui
viennent en appoint pour aider
les professeurs qui feraient ce travail
parce que nous manquons de bras à
l'éducation nationale enfin c'est ce
qu'on nous dit et que donc les
professeurs sont déjà très très occupés
vous savez bien qu'il en manque
quelquefois même dans les dans les
écoles et donc ça serait un surcroît de
charge mais enfin je pense qu'on va
pouvoir trouver quelques heures quand
même par trimestre pour parler de ça et
surtout bâtir
ce qu'on veut dire à chaque étape et
s'adapter vraiment aux plus jeunes
publics donc il faudrait que le Conseil
national les programmes essaye de
concevoir avec tous les meilleurs
spécialistes les pédagogues les
psychologues les sociologues enfin tous
ceux qui peuvent s'occuper le mieux
possible du du cerveau de l'enfant puis
de l'adolescent qu'est-ce qu'il peut
accepter comme image comme parole et peu
à peu le mettre dans un état d'esprit de
où il apprend le consentement où il
apprend ce que c'est que de se respecter
ou peu à peu à l'âge qu'il faut il
apprend les éléments de la sexualité et
en tout cas ça ne doit pas se borner à
mettre en garde les jeunes contre le MST
et les grossesses précoces pour
l'instant c'est ça l'éducation sexuelle
c'est vraiment trop limité c'est très
bien c'est très utile mais il faut
évidemment pas borner le champ de
l'éducation à la vie sexuelle et
affective à ça il faut tout mettre
dedans tout ce qu'on peut
merci puis comme c'est un travail que le
conseil comme le Comité national des
programmes est en train de le faire nous
serons être attentifs à la production du
attendu pour le mois de décembre
l'argument m'a su pour la loi c'est
l'urgence l'urgence chaque minute qui
passe ou c'est séquences ne sont pas
retirées les femmes vont continuer
d'être piégé sur des plateaux de
tournage les images vont continuer
d'être vendues et diffusés les
plateformes vont continuer à se faire
des milliards et ce système tentaculaire
monstrueux et mondial va continuer et
s'il y avait un argument plus bon il a
grande cause du quinquennat quand même
on peut se dire qu'on peut mettre ça en
haut des priorités et la France pourrait
aussi montrer l'exemple on l'a fait déjà
dans le numérique avec les Gafa la
taxation des Gafa et bien on pourrait
montrer l'exemple et l'Europe commençait
par nous suivre et puis le reste du
monde sur une grande avancée pour la
lutte contre la porno criminalité parce
que c'est de la criminalité ce n'est pas
juste de la pornographie il faut lutter
contre la criminalité et donc ce sujet
là doit être une des priorités je pense
que c'est vraiment dès demain donc dans
l'hémicycle un des arguments que vous
pourrez employer auprès du gouvernement
merci pour les socialistes madame Fatiha
kéloua hachis je vous remercie madame la
Présidente merci de votre présence et
les socialistes et le groupe socialiste
est apparentés vous remercie très
sincèrement pour ce rapport nous
soutenons particulièrement votre
recommandation visant à étendre les
pouvoirs le pouvoir de la police
administrative pour permettre le retrait
ou le blocage par farose de toute
atteinte grave à la personne dans le
cadre du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
nous portons des amendements visant à
faire entrer cette recommandation dans
la loi j'aimerais ensuite plus
particulièrement revenir sur deux points
évoqués dans votre rapport premièrement
vous avez souhaité accompagner vos
recommandations visant un calendrier le
secteur de la pornographie par des
mesures de prévention qui sont
absolument essentiels une de vos
recommandations repose sur la mise en
place réelle et effective des séances
d'éducation à la sexualité ce qui est
aujourd'hui loin d'être le cas j'ai été
moi-même enseignante 30 ans dans
l'éducation nationale et je sais de quoi
je parle le Conseil supérieur des
programmes dont je suis membre est
actuellement en train de travailler à la
demande du ministre de l'éducano
national sur ce fameux programme
d'éducation à la sexualité donc selon
vous quels enjeux doivent être intégrés
dans cette réflexion concernant
l'exposition au contenu pornographique
par ailleurs vous revenez dans le
rapport sur les nouveaux phénomènes que
sont les sites MIM et
omnifans vous citez crazy Sally une
youtubeuse mineure qui infiltrait le
site en ligne fans et qui déclare
maintenant on dit que c'est normal avant
on aurait dit que c'était de la
prostitution ces deux plateformes
présentées comme les Instagram du porno
permettent à des personnes parfois
mineurs de vendre des images de leur
corps notamment des contenus à caractère
pornographique quelles sont les
recommandations du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité pour protéger ses mineurs
souvent des femmes des dangers que
représentent ces nouvelles plateformes
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la députée donc
sur l'éducation sexuelle vous avez
compris qu'on n'a pas encore eu le temps
de détailler tout ce qu'on voulait
mettre dedans mais évidemment il y aura
de la prévention sur toutes les images
pornographiques toutes les tous qu'on
peut
dire aux enfants avant qu'ils ne voient
la pour la première fois les images
avant qu'il soit choqués parce que
quelque soit dans quelques-uns d'entre
eux sont choqués à vie sera
utile il vaut mieux montrer prévenir que
guérir et vaut mieux montrer avant en
dédramatisant en disant c'est pas du
tout comme ça dans la vraie vie ça c'est
comme du cinéma malheureusement c'est
pas du vrai cinéma puisque les femmes
souffrent vraiment mais c'est horrible
il faut jamais faire ça et il faut se
mettre à la place des cerveaux des tout
jeunes qui risquent effectivement d'être
traumatisés et il vaut mieux le faire un
petit peu comme un vaccin le rhinoculer
un petit peu d'Hor jeunes en disant ça
c'est mal ça c'est pas bien c'est pas la
norme c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire pour
que peu à peu il n'est pas d'abord
l'envie d'aller regarder plus longuement
et plus fréquemment et qu'ils
comprennent que c'est un interdit parce
que pour l'instant c'est complètement
j'allais dire open bar donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'il dit mais enfin plus qu'on
peut voir que c'est pas interdit ça doit
être la norme il faut absolument leur
faire comprendre que ça n'est pas la
norme que ce n'est pas normal
et je pense qu'il va falloir un
personnel très formé très adapté surtout
pour les plus jeunes mais même pour les
ados pour trouver le langage qui passe
et qui ne les achève pas si je peux dire
parce que c'est vrai que
si on leur montre trop brutalement ce
qui ne doit pas être montré normalement
dans la vie on peut les impressionner
aussi donc c'est un doigté énorme il
faut vraiment être
beaucoup beaucoup réfléchir avant de se
lancer et c'est très bien que le conseil
des programmes d'ailleurs nous sommes
invités à dire ce que nous en pensons
effectivement devant vous
réfléchissent donc cette grille des
programmes pour chaque année pour chaque
âge adapté à chaque âge
ça sera vraiment quelque chose de très
utile et je pense
que évidemment ça doit accompagner la
politique de répression mais la
politique de répression est urgente
parce que l'éducation ça va être long ça
va être très très long et de rattraper
les dégâts va être très long là sur les
jeunes on peut avoir les plus jeunes on
peut avoir une action immédiate mais
pour ceux qui sont déjà complètement
pollués ça va être dur à rattraper après
vous allez j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
au présent un public quand il nous avait
reçu le FCE le 25 janvier je dis vous
pouvez toujours avec votre politique de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
essayer de protéger les femmes et de
mettre les auteurs à l'ombre mais si
vous continuez si vous continuez à
fabriquer des générations détraqués avec
les images de violence qu'on voit en
toute liberté
ça va être le tonneau des Danaïdes donc
effectivement il faut absolument arrêter
à la source mais dans l'urgence Pharos
farros voilà alors pour le phénomène les
nouveaux phénomènes de de cyber
pornographie si je puis dire il faut
nous proposons qu'évidemment soit étendu
assez plateformes la même législation
contre la Constitution le proxénétisme
il faut voir les ce que c'est il faut
appeler un chat un chat et c'est la pure
prostitution donc là nous demandons à ce
que soit étendu les dispositions quand
on le proxénétisme à ce genre de
pratique je crois qu'il faut vraiment
prendre le taureau par les cornes et je
puis dire tous les bouts c'est peut-être
pas très heureux comme expression mais
vraiment par toutes les manifestations
sur internet de toute cette activité
monstrueuse malheureusement réprimer on
en est là je suis pas une une sorcière
dans l'âme et je suis quelqu'un de très
ouverte mais vraiment là ce n'est plus
possible on a atteint un niveau de
violence qui n'est simplement plutôt les
rat pour la société
ça marche pas merci pour le groupe
horizon Anne-Cécile violon
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues
madame la Présidente tout d'abord je
tiens à vous remercier d'être présente
aujourd'hui c'est pas la première fois
qu'on vous auditionne en DDF et c'est
toujours un plaisir et un véritable
honneur vous incarnez véritablement avec
force et convictions ce combat qui le
vôtre qui est le nôtre alors au nom du
groupe horizon et à parenté je souhaite
vraiment vous féliciter pour la qualité
de votre travail sur votre rapport avec
votre toute votre équipe mais aussi mais
aussi souligner votre pugnacité lors de
l'émission cash investigation car il en
faut il en faut pour faire face aux
tentatives de minimalisation ou de
banalisation parfois
alors tout le monde l'a cité ce chiffre
je crois qu'on a tous été sidérés par
beaucoup de chiffres mais celui-ci 90%
de contenu pour pornographiques qui
contiennent de la violence et quelle
violence et si je le mets en lien avec
l'exposition à la pornographie des
mineurs qui a considérablement augmenté
en 5 ans en passant de 19% en 17 à 28%
on se rend compte qu'effectivement les
jeunes sont en recherche de contenu
sexuels sur les sites pornographiques ce
qu'ils appellent leur tuto sexo et c'est
ce qu'on avait pu identifier que ma
collègue Pascal Martin lors de notre
rapport sur la santé mentale des femmes
et c'est là tout l'enjeu de la
sensibilité de nos jeunes enfants c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des recommandations
qu'on a pu faire
explicitement dans ce rapport il est
indispensable que nos jeunes aient accès
à des contenus pédagogiques concrets
afin de ne pas aller chercher ailleurs
et donc sur des sites pornos leur
réponse vous l'avez parfaitement dit ne
passant parer de cette question
d'éducation sexuelle c'est cautionner
une modification fondamentale de notre
rapport à la sexualité déformer
conditionner par la violence et
l'objectalisation de la femme
alors je souhaite revenir sur votre
expérience avec le site internet Pharos
qui permet de ce signalement des
contenus vous l'avez dit pas de suite
absence d'effets suite au signalement de
ces contenus alors évidemment là on est
limité effectivement par par la loi il
est indispensable de passer à l'étape
supérieure et de pouvoir absolument
intégrer les contenus de violence et de
barbarie
c'est indispensable qu'on soit à cette
étape là pardon
lors de vos échanges avec le ministère
et votre expertise sur le site Pharos
alors qu'en est-il est-ce que vous avez
pu obtenir des réponses justement
concrètes sur le plan technologique
quels sont les failles qu'est-ce qui
peut nous quelles sont les failles ou
quelles sont les outils qui peuvent
véritablement nous amener à pouvoir être
vraiment efficace parce que je crois que
c'est vraiment l'enjeu vous l'avez dit
on est dans l'urgence et il nous faut
des outils c'est madame la Présidente de
la DDF qui veut répondre manifestement
en tout cas voilà vous n'êtes pas une
chanceuse vous êtes vous contribuez
évidemment à la sauvegarde de nos
valeurs à la dignité de notre société et
un immense merci
merci à vous et pour les mots personnels
qui me touchent évidemment beaucoup et
pour moi aussi c'est toujours un plaisir
de venir devant vous toutes et tous
parce que on a une oreille spécialement
attentive chez vous évidemment
deux mots sur effectivement l'éducation
sexuelle on y revient on est d'accord si
on ne le fait pas c'est le la
pornographie qui sera à l'école du
sexisme l'école des violences sexuelles
l'école de la barbarie donc il vaudrait
mieux le faire à la vraie école que sur
internet sur farose techniquement
comment ça se passe en réalité
Pharos
est chargé pour le terrorisme et la
pédopornographie donc de faire retirer
c'est pas lui qui le fait c'est pas la
plateforme qui le fait il demande quand
il voit qu'il y a des contenus qui sont
illégaux qui de faire retirer par les
hébergeurs si les hébergeurs ne le font
pas assez vite ils demandent au
fournisseur d'accès en France de faire
cesser
l'URL enfin donc il y a plus d'image
donc c'est très très simple de faire la
même chose pour des scènes de violence
vu la techniquement ça ne pose aucun
problème même si on dit mais il y a une
masse de contenu et ils viennent de
l'étranger le fait qu'il vienne de
l'étranger effectivement en pêche un peu
que les hébergeurs
qui
diffusent ces sites
obéissent mais à ce moment-là on a le
fournisseur d'accès et ça il est en
France enfin Orange Free il s'exécute
ils sont en France ils obéissent à la
loi française et
quant à la masse qui fait un peu peur
mais deux arguments d'une part je vous
ai dit l'intelligence artificielle qui
peut ça c'est le ministre lui-même
monsieur Darmanin qui nous l'a dit Paola
notre état général que je remercie au
passage parce que sans elle l'ignorant
rien ne serait possible ouais je sais
donc il faut quand même qu'on le sache
toute l'équipe d'ailleurs mais beaucoup
Paola donc
nous étions dans le bureau de Monsieur
Darmanin et une dizaine de jours et je
lui ai dit je sais peut-être ça pose un
problème de RH non pas de problème de RH
avec l'intelligence artificielle on
balaye les séquences on peut très bien
sélectionner les images problématiques
donc de ce côté là et pas de problème et
après on demande aux hébergeurs puis aux
fournisseur d'accès de procéder
techniquement
à la coupe donc
l'avantage en plus de ce système c'est
que une fois qu'on aura fait ça pendant
quelques semaines je vous assure que les
producteurs qui veulent gagner de
l'argent avec la pub qui entoure la
diffusion de leurs images si ils ont
plus leur argent ils vont arrêter de
produire donc ça va se tarir très vite
il y a la force de l'exemple
tout je vais vous raconter ce que
j'avais fait sur dans l'audiovisuel
c'est beaucoup plus petit c'est moins
grave mais ça a été quand même la même
logique quand madame Belkacem nous a
confié au CSA ça s'appelait encore CSA à
l'époque l'arcom le soin de veiller à
l'image des femmes dans l'audiovisuel il
fallait donc lutter contre le sexisme
les agressions sexuelles à la télé et à
la radio monsieur Hanouna a procédé à
quelques agressions sexuelles sur ces
plateaux nous l'avons mis en demeure
puis
sanctionner d'une somme importante
c'était pas lui d'ailleurs c'était la
chaîne qui le diffusait la chaîne Canal
a dû payer 3 millions
comme comme sanction et notre sanction
qui est évidemment
refusé dans le principe par la chaîne et
passer devant le Conseil d'État qui nous
a donné raison donc après cette
jurisprudence qui aura lieu aussi avec
pharoscopharos va et je laisse comme je
l'espère retirer des séquences les
producteurs vont commencer par dire ils
avaient pas le droit c'est pas que c'est
pas conforme à la liberté de création de
tout ce qu'on veut il y aura une
jurisprudence et la jurisprudence comme
le Conseil d'État a fait pour nous nous
donnera donnera raison à la loi et ça
s'arrêtera et Monsieur Hanouna continue
malheureusement sur beaucoup d'autres
thèmes mais sur les femmes ça s'est
arrêté donc je pense que pour ce qui est
de la production de séquence atroces
pour les femmes si les les plateformes
n'ayant plus intérêt parce qu'elles
n'ont plus l'argent
ça s'arrêtera donc c'est un des
meilleurs moyens il faut les toucher aux
portefeuille pour les toucher au
portefeuille il faut que les productions
ne puissent plus avoir lieu parce
qu'elles ne sont plus diffusées et on
aura gagné donc je fais un rêve voilà je
pense qu'on peut y arriver avec vous
merci madame la Présidente nous sommes
arrivés à la fin des orateurs et
oratrices de groupe et donc nous passons
j'ai deux personnes qui souhaitent poser
des questions pour le groupe Renaissance
Sophie panonacle merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la Présidente du
Haut Conseil à l'égalité pour nous
alerter sur ce fléau j'appellerai ça un
fléau juste une remarque
sur ma circonscription on essaie de
travailler avec les établissements
scolaires et ce n'est pas si simple que
ça vous parliez d'éducation à la
sexualité moi je pense que l'éducation à
la sécurité c'est une chose mais tous
les les enseignants ne peuvent pas tout
faire on peut pas tout leur demander et
par rapport aux violences aux violences
de manière générale les associations
peuvent aller dans certains
établissements et peut-être de manière
plus proche avec les élèves en tout cas
de manière différente venir expliquer ce
qui se passe et venir témoigner de de
ces violences de ces difficultés et en
tout cas alerter les jeunes sur la
pornographie nous pourrions faire la
même chose à condition et je voudrais
avoir votre avis que les établissements
qu'on les encourage ou peut-être plus
qu'on les encourage d'ailleurs quand les
incident davantage à ouvrir leurs portes
à ces associations c'est une vraie
difficulté aujourd'hui sur les violences
tous les établissements ne sont pas
obligés ne sont pas contraints d'ouvrir
leurs portes
à nos nombreuses associations de qualité
qui pourraient faire compléter faire un
excellent travail donc votre avis sur
sur ce sujet tout à fait d'accord avec
vous beaucoup d'associations avec
lesquelles nous travaillons
journellement puisque nous sommes les
représentants des associations en HCE
nous ont d'ailleurs fait part de leur
déception parce qu'elles n'ont pas pu
répondre à la demande de certains lycées
ou certains collèges parce que
elles-mêmes n'ont plus l'argent pour le
pour financer ces activités donc il y a
à la fois des collèges et des lycées qui
sont un peu fermés à ce type d'activités
qui ont peur de la réaction des parents
de de même des certains élèves il y a
cette peur a surmonter qui doit être
surmonté par l'établissement d'un
programme bien public bien discuté avec
tout le monde et qui fasse l'objet d'un
consensus pour qu'il y ait pas de
dérapage possible ou pas de doute
possible mais aussi des moyens à donner
aux associations pour qu'elles puissent
continuer à vivre elles sont de plus en
plus sollicitées
c'est bien ça montre que les femmes vont
de plus en plus chercher dans les
associations du soutien et des relais
mais
les pouvoirs publics ont augmenté les
dotations des associations ça va jamais
aussi vite malheureusement que la
musique et donc certaines associations
manquent un peu d'argent pour financer
leur propre personnel et tout le monde
n'est pas bénévole il peut pas faire ça
toute la journée bénévolement pour aller
travailler dans les collèges et les
lycées donc je dirais qu'il y a un
double mouvement à faire
rassurer les professeurs les proviseurs
et les parents d'élèves là où il y a des
doutes et je sais pas si vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé en Belgique récemment à
propos des cours l'éducation sexuelle il
y a eu des levés de boucliers
épouvantables des scènes de violence
enfin c'est incroyable de la paranoïa de
certains parents ou certaines familles
et de la violence sur ce sujet donc il
faudrait pas que ça repartes ici à
l'occasion de la mise en place de ses
cours très utile donc il faut rassurer
tout le monde côté parents et et
professeur ce qui n'ont pas envie de
faire ça il faut pas les obliger mais il
faut que ce soit des personnels
volontaires que ce soit des associations
ou des
enseignants les former se mettent
d'accord sur le programme et pour ce qui
est des associations leur permettre
effectivement de répondre à la demande
elles sont un peu en manque cruel de
moyens et donc je je vous fais un appel
pour elle parce que je me fais le relais
c'est vrai que la demande est forte mais
elles peuvent pas pourvoir à tout donc
je pense qu'un double mouvement à
enclencher
merci la parole est à Mireille la peau
merci madame la Présidente donc madame
la Présidente du HCE merci pour tous ces
travaux je m'associe à ce qui a été dit
votre rapport il fait froid dans le dos
moi j'avoue qu'il m'a appris des choses
déjà comme je suis l'une des rapporteurs
de ce projet de loi sereine j'ai
participé à une audition
et c'est vrai que dans toute sa crudité
vous dénoncez des choses absolument
abominables donc j'ignorais jusqu'à
l'existence donc je le dis de façon
ferme il n'y a aucune justification à
cette exploitation de femmes ou
d'enfants ou d'hommes et j'exprime mon
dégoût de ces pratiques pornos
criminelles et en plus je le redis je
suis vraiment consciente des dégâts que
cette exposition précoce et régulière à
la violence la cruauté la porno
criminalité peut faire envers nos
enfants et c'est une question de santé
publique j'ai noté une expression que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure on fabrique
des générations de détraqué avec ce
business et c'est d'ailleurs assez fort
de voir le contraste entre les trois
pointes de ce triangle maléfique si on
peut dire les consommateurs ceux qui
sont consommateurs je dirais conscient
quand une jouissance addictive le
business du porno et ça a été dit c'est
pour faire de l'argent c'est un bull
lucratif et puis les victimes et
d'ailleurs je me posais la question de
quid de des victimes est-ce que on
arrive à les accompagner à les soigner
parce que ça doit être un traumatisme
terrible après ces crimes alors je dis
tout ça et malgré tout comme nous sommes
législateur je voudrais ouvrir un débat
et donc apporter une nuance à ce qui
était dit parce que si c'était facile
ça aurait été fait je pense et
et je pense qu'on est quand même dans
une zone un peu grise alors pourquoi je
m'explique
vous savez que
toute loi qu'on fait doit passer au
filtre de la constitutionnalité et donc
il n'est pas sûr que la
constitutionnalité de ces mesures que
vous prenez soit acquises on a eu une
expérience en 2019
vous affirmez que la non simulation est
évidente mais quand même là aussi est-ce
que ça passerait la barrière de la
Constitution et puis qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec les représentations
littéraires au cinématographique
antérieur je pensais en en parler hier
au dernier tango à Paris où il y a à la
fin une scène de sodomie non consentie
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que ces
représentations là
est-ce que vous les mettez dans le même
sac ou est-ce que pour vous c'est
complètement différent merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup alors d'abord
sur le dernier envoi à Paris la scène
était
si si elle l'a dit dans les interviews
non non
l'acte n'a pas été perpétré c'était
montré pour faire croire que non j'ai
relu toutes les interviews justement
enfin bon
si si elle n'avait je pense qu'elle
aurait si elle n'était pas contente et
elle a l'aurait dénoncé elle aurait
porté plainte mais enfin bon je j'ai lu
des interviews disant que elle n'avait
pas été pénétrée qu'elle avait été
surprise qu'on lui impose ce type de
scène mais qu'elle n'avait pas été
pénétrée mais qu'on lui avait imposé une
scène de supposer sodomie enfin bon ça
c'est un point refermant la parenthèse
sur la constitutionnalité qui est votre
point le plus important il se trouve que
j'ai pu en parler avec le président de
conséquationnelle enfin ça reste un peu
entre nous c'était pas officiel on a une
discussion il m'a félicité en juillet
dernier
pour les positions que nous venions de
prendre à l'occasion du du de la
être conséquationnelles et dire ben non
ces scènes circulaient il y a rien à
voir c'est pas attentatoire à la dignité
humaine il y a pas de violence et de
barbarie une fois de plus
toutes ces scènes ne sont pas du cinéma
ce n'est pas simulé les souffrances
réelles et ça se voit infligez-vous le
spectacle de ces séquences je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez fait il suffit de
regarder ça deux minutes on suffoque et
ça n'est pas possible de mimer une
souffrance pareille les les objets et
les pénis introduits chez ces femmes
sont réelles les trous sont réels quand
on voit des femmes et viscérées je vous
ai pas dit le pire tout à l'heure le
prolapse alors je vais vous l'infliger
pour vous persuader madame que ça ne
peut pas être inventé le prolapse c'est
quand le vagin ou l'anus d'une dame est
tellement défoncée par des pénétrations
multiples et brutales que les intestins
les organes intérieurs sortent voilà et
bien écoutez des scènes comme ça je ne
sais pas comment le conseil cautionnel
peut dire attention c'est peut-être
simulé c'est peut-être de la création
c'est peut-être du cinéma je crois pas
une seconde je crois qu'au contraire ils
applaudiront dès demain une loi qui
permettrait d'éliminer ce genre de
torture sur internet en liberté
on reste un peu sans voix merci pour la
parole est à Béatrice Descamps
merci Madame les présidentes la
présidente merci pour votre apport pour
votre travail et votre présence ici
aujourd'hui à nouveau aujourd'hui
ma question va peut-être paraître un peu
comme on dirait un superficiel mais je
tenais quand même à l'aborder vous avez
rappelé insisté sur le fait que
l'éducation nationale ne joue pas
suffisamment son rôle en la matière
d'éducation sexuelle
et ce depuis trop longtemps
vous avez raison je partage vous avez
dit aussi que ces sujets étaient
difficilement abordables au sein de la
famille en tout cas de certaines
familles et je voudrais rebondir
là-dessus ne croyez-vous pas que notre
rôle est aussi de faire évoluer les
mentalités en aidant les familles en les
mettant face aux dangers que sont ceux
de l'utilisation des écrans pour les
enfants parce que je pense qu'il y a une
méconnaissance de ces dangers je faisais
partie des députés du Forum citoyen sur
le sujet et je peux vous dire que voilà
c'est pour ça que je me permets de
revenir sur ce sujet et aussi beaucoup
de parents ont besoin d'être aidés que
ce soit dans cette matière que sur la
matière d'éducation sexuelle ne
croyez-vous pas que nous avons un rôle
aussi à jouer en plus de celui de
l'éducation nationale
bien sûr madame la députée c'est évident
les familles ont un rôle énorme à jouer
quand d'ailleurs j'étais encore au CSA
et ça continue aujourd'hui on faisait
des campagnes énormes d'abord pour dire
attention pas d'écran avant 3 ans et
après faites attention à ce que vous
enfant voit ils peuvent être marqué à
vie il y a quand même encore dans
l'audiovisuel des des des
scènes épouvantables et il y a
maintenant surtout sur leur smartphone
des des choses vraiment
qui ne devrait pas être mis devant tous
les yeux donc les parents ont un rôle
énorme à jouer simplement vous savez
très bien beaucoup de parents ne sont
pas là il y a les mêmes familles
monoparentales il y a c'est c'est
smartphone qu'on se passe dans la cour
entre grand et petit le cousin enfin
c'est très très difficile d'empêcher un
enfant jeune d'être en contact avec ces
images
et donc il faut évidemment alerter les
parents trouver les moyens de blocage
les plus efficaces possibles condition
les enfants pour que ça laisse ça les
dégoûte de regarder ça plutôt que ça ne
les attire on peut essayer toutes les
méthodes la meilleure encore c'est qu'il
y est pas ces images et qu'elle n'existe
plus et c'est donc que je pour ça que je
me bats tellement oui ça règleait tout
il y aurait plus ces images de torture
ça traumatiserait plus personne bon il y
aurait plus les filles et viscéraires
mais il y aurait plus non plus les
enfants détraqués donc je pense quand
même c'est une méthode peut-être un peu
radicale mais qui est la plus efficace
parce que l'éducation
les systèmes de blocage tout ça c'est
très joli les parents bien sûr mais vous
savez il faut dire qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de parents qui regardent ces
fameux séquences
un tiers des Français regarde ce porno
on est le troisième pays au monde le
plus consommateur alors bon je veux bien
faire confiance aux parents je suis tout
à fait d'accord généralement les parents
de jeunes enfants sont conscients de
leur tâches mais enfin bon il y a des
gens devant ces images il y a des
consommateurs donc je préférais qui plus
ces images voilà et je ne comprends pas
je vais vous dire un truc personnel
comment on peut jouir devant des images
pareil c'est pour moi un mystère absolu
bien qu'il faut être tolérant mais enfin
quand même c'est quand même quelque
chose
d'étrange voilà je leur ai dit
merci infiniment je crois qu'on a eu
l'ensemble des orateurs et des questions
vous validez ok merci infiniment pour
votre présence chers Sylvie et puis qui
nous permettra d'éclairer nos débats dès
demain et qui devrait se poursuivre
jeudi peut-être lundi voilà en tout cas
on espère que on pourra faire avancer
avoir une réponse
efficace et à la hauteur pour ces femmes
merci merci à vous ça a été vraiment un
grand plaisir et un moment d'émotion
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on vit
quelque chose de peut-être historique ce
que vous aurez à faire dans les deux
trois prochains jours si vous arrivez à
faire voter quelque chose vraiment vous
aurez fait avancer l'humanité